hey ice going bros my name is welcome
back to episode 2 part 2 final it's
really confused season 3 like what it's
happening all you need to know it's
intense
are they following us just the other car
looks like we're okay
we don't know where Clementine is and I
don't like that
not one thing it'd be fun if we see some
old camel it's been a while
thank God we'd seen Clementine but you
believe it all of our friends all those
people they just love to introduce new
characters
[Music]
she deserved better
they all deserve better you barely knew
her but the hell do you care
hey I helped her win someone who open
fire she's dead because of you
Conrad easy buddy this wasn't his fault
[ __ ] Francine there's Clementine
Prescott all because this washed-up
cheat walked through our gates I should
have known it the second I looked at you
we we just lost someone too so say what
you have to say what that's supposed to
make me feel better
calm down Conrad please all I know is if
it wasn't for him uh-oh back the [ __ ]
off now oh it's time for a little boy to
be a man huh time to get that bean yeah
just back away take it easy son Gabriel
put it away now he's gonna hurt you no
way just do it already I don't even care
anymore just put it down Gabe Gabe don't
make me repeat myself
don't touch my uncle again
[Music]
okay let him go he just needs to cool
off you have to go back we have to bury
her I wish we could but
Prescott's overrun we can't go back
what about well we're not safe here
either am i heard about Richmond I've
heard there's a community there if it's
true they'll have food walls maybe even
a hospital Wow is to find the
[ __ ] who did this they took my
home
they took mom god damn it the one thing
we all need is a place to call home
maybe Richmond can be that place well
that wasn't Richmond huh it's something
at least yeah [ __ ] it let's go how quick
was that guy to give up on his whole
town okay you didn't even bring anything
but he's over all oh that's cute huh
maybe I'll hit it off
excuse me he's not ready it's healthy
for you he is not ready for Clementine
let me tell you dad you need someone
else to talk to you that understands
what you're going through so I'm out
guys got a long drive ahead of us I'm in
time badass
Gabriel [ __ ] [ __ ] all right
sorry that's really gross I just
realized that program
Oh see I forgot I forgot it they brought
her what can I do for you here I just I
feel like I'm burning up and I'm dying
of thirst we got water
[Music]
hopefully it's not urine here you go
it's kind of sketchy
thirsty isn't good how's her forehead
feel
Oh hot hot [ __ ] it's probably sepsis
sooner we get to Richmond the better
you're thirsty you're hot you guys like
whatever no it really hurts
hey you're gonna be fine Kate I'm just
trying to be realistic
yeah I'm trying to be optimistic
[Music]
a hobby we both know what's coming
shame we do
and this is gonna sound [ __ ] up but
maybe this is my chance for Christ
I don't know graceful exit not many
people get this gate gave my heuu he's
gonna have to deal with this sooner or
later and just think about all that's
happened
Mariana died him I couldn't stop him and
Gabe I heard what happened when we
stopped isn't it obvious
look he might be turning into David he
might be turning into you he's not that
sweet little boy I first met he just
needs guidance and a lot of it
and I hope so all I care about is
becoming who he needs to be and it's
gonna be on you to make sure that
happens
I don't want her to die no ma'am
I'm not buying this I'm dying [ __ ] it's
on both of us you're buying it whether
you want to or not oh hey careful
sorry raccoon you should get some rest
we all should really with pleasure
her parents just love pretending the
rest of us can't hear
awkward I wouldn't know oh oh
the game last chapter coming up last one
had four if I remember correctly so it's
about to go down in Viking town hey it's
me
Oh did great what now I've got some bad
news
let me guess we're lost not exactly what
then well we got a bunch of cars
clogging the underpass too many to drive
through we're gonna need to move some of
them out of the way hey I'm coming too
I'll stay with Kate and keep a lookout
yeah what else if anything happens
awfully convenient the pass is blocked
like this not convenient at all if you
ask me yeah that's the point it's a trap
it's a trap nothing for Clement and he
needs her own theme
that was [ __ ] badass if we move that
car right there we should be good ever
times the [ __ ] come on [ __ ] let's get to
work and clear it out I love Clementine
so much she's my favorite character
after Lee of course Jesus hell are we
gonna get that out of the way
let's see any tow trucks so we can't
push it huh or can we
by putting it off gear sorry don't roll
your eyes to me young man how are we
doing yeah Conrad doesn't look too good
over there tell me about it
he's a good man hobby known him a long
time this is just a dark day for him
yeah
keep an eye on him for me all right oh
my god it says dab oh damn it I said tab
[ __ ] I hate when it says jab instead of
dab it's the worst thing Hey
all right maybe we can find something in
this garage open please oh geez dude got
a [ __ ] wrench sweet man I'll take
I'll take the French Swedish invention
by the way quick Nikhil you're welcome
all right
you're welcome videos the hour it
somehow
we need to pay rate somehow how about we
use the rate John yes now I can part the
cable now I can follow at the KIBRA
it's gotta be way to power this thing
how the Quran connect hopefully that'll
hold still need something to power this
puppy
thanks for helping Viking dude oh [ __ ]
winch perhaps that something else that
we can find oh look a dad we could talk
to jab no his name is Conrad I guess we
should talk to everyone I kind of like
this down moments in the game its brings
atmosphere it brings me great pleasure
and joy
so you and Clementine talking back there
so you're hitting that we were just
talking is the art I'm [ __ ] killed
she seems pretty cool uh-huh uh-huh
pretty cool how old are you huh not old
enough
now those might come in handy if you
touch Clementine I'm a touch shoot no
wait imma kill you
hey jumper cables let's just talk to
khun rent you good
nah man I'm not good you don't ask
something you get I know your friend dad
let's just get this [ __ ] over with you
can't get to Richmond alright sounds
good to me
I don't give a [ __ ] Conrad the real hair
of the story is Loni I shouldn't disturb
her she's resting I should ask her if
she knew Lonnie Lonnie was my man he was
my main [ __ ] dude that was there an axe
next to him it's okay I did this during
a scare PewDiePie I know what I'm doing
it's easy pop the hood I mean I could
have done that you should better not
mess up my baby here that'll do
now run the engine here goes nothing
Hey there we go I think we're set
what apostle Oh No Walker son be ready
to move once the wreck is clear we
should be right behind you
there's still not gonna end well I know
this game Hey look at that zombie
oh my god it's more jacked
I love hey next time close to your
[ __ ] windows whoa [ __ ] yeah that's oh
my god yes yes yes that's cool I'll
shoot you and then you and then you and
then you and then you and then
Clementine would kick some ass orange no
go go go
just drive get into Richmond
they're through let's go dude
oh dude look go into your lap I'll do it
that was awesome
oh thanks buddy Thanks
[ __ ]
dijanna bigger problems here roof it's a
fire
how did so many of them just come out of
nowhere
like nowhere convenient plot device
zombies now everywhere hey dad there's
no point in wasting bullets here but
okay
Oh bah that'll take you out
is getting intent
you can't climb that come on
god damn it I knew this place didn't
feel right fairies don't do now that
right we have to come up with some kind
of plan we don't have a choice
we got to fight our way out Oh My gods
great this is just [ __ ] great what
the hell are we gonna do
calm down calm down I'm not gonna
[ __ ] cry dr. Planet I like that
[ __ ] Mikey man this mess if it wasn't
for you it's not true
[ __ ] you come on oh stop there's
somebody over there what where [ __ ]
everybody get down
wait what's a solar trap keep your heads
down
I could have a rifle whoever you are you
should know we've got guns and we're
prepared to use them
it's a Cana hell
it's the Kenny he's gone everyone stay
here and keep behind cover I'm gonna see
what I can find out be careful
oh yeah add it I don't think I can't
kill Kenny in this playthrough I now
remember I actually did kill him WASD
Thank You game ah
Wow
Clementine is literally the only
character left from season one it's a
bit sad
and now I would aim the gun at him and
be like hey what's up how's it going bro
it's pity pie here did you watch my
channel I'm gonna need you to turn
around for me
slowly did you hear me
it's a [ __ ]
uh help
that thing's not a toy drop it or you
might hurt yourself now then I'm not
gonna shoot not unless you made me I
just want to talk
you got me just want to have a word
so talk okay then you the two guys
they're the kids the women in the car I
saw you split up I overheard that little
argument just now your friends over
there are gonna shoot me right
you folks have your [ __ ] together if
you're some kind of broken tribe then
let me know now they're good people
they've lost a lot sure we all have
recently ah fresh wounds that makes
sense you're going to Richmond that
tells me you got something to do with
what's going on down there
question is whose side are you want look
man I don't know oh [ __ ] I wasn't ready
for this he doesn't seem man I don't
think we should shoot enough
don't move
America everyone has guns
hello that there's no shortage of
elements in this game to see one of them
hey man what do you mean by them who's
them you know what I'm talking about
the new frontier what no I'm not with
those guys you got this backwards Bobby
this guy's full of Donkey [ __ ]
do you want to let me talk what's the
point how can we trust anything you say
I don't think he's with those guys look
I'm telling you I'm on my way to
Richmond just like you I lost touch with
some good people there when the new
frontier took over what did you say
the new frontier they took over Richmond
oh don't tell me you didn't know that
that's bad that's real bad [ __ ] oh god
Eleanor Kate they're headed right into
the middle of those [ __ ] at least
now we got an excuse to go after those
[ __ ] what are we gonna do we
need to go now real [ __ ] [ __ ] we need
to go good one who's been skulking
around you got any ideas there's an old
train tunnel that runs under the James
River from what I hear it should be a
straight shot into Richmond
what is climbing a tree tunnel I could
lead you guys there but since a hobby
here said you're good people and all
maybe you could lower those guns First
Lord in my ass I'll tie you up and make
sure your story checks out that's really
not necessary
lower your guns Bobby man don't you
trust me or not
I want to know what Clementine things
cuz I only really trust her ready this
way hey what do we call you
sorry forgot to introduce myself it's
Paul but my friends call me Jesus
how about that we met Jesus
what a weird dude oh we got a Clementine
flashback coming up and let's see what
it says 4 ok so there's 5 then I suppose
sorry sorry
there we go
yeah what happened to little Timmy I
know that's not his name we can hide in
here don't worry it's gonna be okay
come on that seems like a terrible idea
hey JJ it's alright you're hungry babies
are the worst
humming stunning wait did the zombie
whom is welcome to go and then we're
gonna find you some dinner hopefully
find us some dinner
who the [ __ ] are you please don't leave
me out here seems harmless honestly [ __ ]
hey there hello
pretty big group of them out there stay
right where you are don't move don't
worry kill I'm not going anywhere
looks like we're gonna there was an open
door Oh long talk
Hey look at that dammit well I'd say we
make a pretty good team
I roll alone I'm claiming pain you like
apples or too bad it's not my looks the
three of us I mean you and I are not a
team this is my team pretty small team
we could have survived without you yeah
well I couldn't have survived without
you and I'm not too big to admit it is
it you kid
you guys live in here you seem kind of
young to be a mom what are you 13
I knew his parents but they're gone now
I'm all he has and he's cute and lucky
he has someone looking after not much of
that anymore we were out there scouting
nothing out of the ordinary and then
ordinary and then chaos and [ __ ]
most bastards are slow but god damn it
when there's another one I got separated
from the others god I hope they all made
it
I thought we were ready for anything but
they were all around us before he saw
them
what were you scouting for gas water any
supplies we could find really sure as
hell was worth it
my people are probably at the rendezvous
by now what's left of them at least by
the way no I got this creepy night we
call ourselves the new frontier Oh
she interacted with them before I should
have guessed why don't you come with me
meet my people my food blankets no I
don't I don't you come on dinner's on me
groups aren't really my thing
no woman is an island have it your way
but you did me a solid here I won't
forget it next time we cross paths there
is no next time we'll see the world does
work in mysterious ways [ __ ] does that
mean hate when they okay you're just
gonna sleep there and you're IKEA pillow
[Music]
oh my god well that was Clementine flags
time to abandon decades ago but I've
heard you can get through yours open Oh
javi I need to talk to you
ma what does she know what I know
something she knows something
what is the Clementine shouldn't you
keeping quiet about me and the new
frontier but what I told you earlier
it's not the whole truth
oh maybe she's marked I wasn't their
prisoner oh no I should have told you
sooner
Claire my time really should have oh my
god what their brand you just listen I'm
not asking you to forgive me but you
have to understand I had nobody
[Music]
I was all alone and I thought I didn't
need them but they were very persuasive
this is super awkward can't believe you
Leila content to you with the fire
everything it was a mistake and so was
not telling you about it tell me you're
not still one of them no way believe me
I just had to explain because if they're
really in control in Richmond I can't
let them see me I just can't well the
story adds up plus the course entrance
tunnel I'm leaving y'all planning on
joining us Shh Jesus clearly hey yeah
you all hear that can you see anything
it's jacksepticeye oh that's creepy you
might say that
I am that one that one oh [ __ ] they're
everywhere [ __ ] they are keep sharp what
the [ __ ] does that mean
watch out
oh [ __ ] Bobby help G says oh my god it
chase us JS - Quranic Jason take him out
oh my god
holy moly oh mighty Conrad Walker the
[ __ ] County is gonna be heading this
way follow me let go in the tunnel they
said it would be a good idea they said
what the [ __ ] no one ever mentioned it
raining
we've got to find a way around it we're
[ __ ] dinner maybe we could just go
through well does it open this is real
bad this is real bad let me tell you I
know when things up behind your babies
javi and I will block the door you guys
go ahead and make sure it's clean I get
fast
I'll be right ahead of you staying here
hold the door shut until I can find
something to barricade it worry not
[ __ ] I'm gonna have to break this thing
off they're almost here
okay well I suppose I could do that
hobby
it's too many help it's baseball time
okay let's go we got it oh she knows I
wouldn't touch that gun girl
you either cowboy how are you doing I
heard you - you think I'm stupid finish
your little story now we we need to keep
moving you need to talk
whatever you think you heard you heard
it wrong [ __ ] roll up your sleeve why
I [ __ ] knew it you wanted them to
goddamn why she is that can't believe it
climbing time the [ __ ] did you shut
down our throats hi [ __ ] believable
just let me go let you go you're too
valuable for that don't you see we bring
her to Richmond they'll give us whatever
we want medical help for Kate she's our
bargaining chip they won't bargain with
you you don't know them well know until
we try she's not a bargaining chip
she's a friend God that for a dancer
go to hell Conrad I'm not doing this you
want to shoot me shoot me how about I
shoot your little boyfriend is yes yes
easy
you ain't hassle anybody oh my god tell
Clem this is how it's gonna be and then
we all started sunshine come on man be
reasonable this helps both of them know
just gonna go take another step please
you know this will work holy [ __ ] yeah
God you two should go what about you
I'll find my own way
he was a good name he's dead God it just
happened so fast
it had to be ten I had no other choice I
know you just don't look at me like that
feels different I don't let's go
that was a tough decision I gotta say to
run on the fly I wanted to think about
it for a second but I you know Gabriel
and Clementine are important to me all
right I don't really care about Khan
right so what am I supposed to do huh
where's Conrad uh he did not make it out
he's he's gone he didn't make it up
I'm sorry so that's it he just oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] try to stay quiet jesus [ __ ]
christ
damn it Conrad and the girl where is she
or should we assume the worst she ran
off I just don't know what the hell is
going on anymore
yeah what a [ __ ] show this isn't what
any of us wanted but right now we need
to find Kate and Eleanor what is he why
would he care at this point about okay
you're right
I just wish I'm sorry dude I'm really
sorry for killing your friend that's
gonna that's gonna that's gonna bite me
in the ass later I am sure
[Music]
the gates are this way but I'd leave if
your people are here that's where they
would ended up and links me up Jesus I'm
nurse signed you know that makes me feel
good why is it so quiet I thought
there'd be new frontier marching in the
streets and [ __ ] practicing on walkers
or whatever the [ __ ] they do it does
seem strangely quiet maybe we just got
lucky
who is someone watching us I feel
watched
I feel very watched over watch okay then
ah [ __ ] did they see us I don't think so
can you see anything javi what are they
doing creepy looking that's their quarry
keep it down
[Music]
they're not in the car she said take can
you hear me
hey talk to me
say stop come on King javi okay yes
could really use something to take the
edge off right about now
oh Jesus you scared the hell out of me
Hey are you are you okay come here
where's Eleanor she she won't I had to
get help she hasn't come back damn it
they must have got her
Jesus how far is it to their car not too
much farther couple blocks at most
Gabe help me lift her up I'm thinking
Kate's not gonna make it much longer so
it's time we walk up to the front door
and say hello all right fine
here we go
hopefully we got there before the other
guys you know
[Music]
there it is New Richmond
we're here Kate I'm gonna get you inside
okay
Oh lovey if they can save me how about
you have me finally take that trip
tonight
that's me you don't want to go to Norway
the Northern Lights season 100% of that
apple green and purple what would you
say this somewhere warmer
I hear Bora Bora is great this time of
year Jesus there's a solid possibility
this isn't gonna go our way if you want
to stay behind I wouldn't blame you
hey this is where I was going in the
first place looks so nice and inviting
hey uh-oh
you again you must have some kind of
death wish she needs medical help and
you have one of our people
uh-huh what's your point after what you
did to our people I'm not inclined to
help any I know we both got a bone to
pick here but we can hash that out later
she needs to get to the hospital or
she's gonna die stupid then I guess
she's gonna die it was your men that
shot her your bullets you owe it to us
to help now that is we don't owe you
[ __ ]
angry it's got nothing to do with me
your people your problem she dies I'm
holding you personally responsible just
cause you say something doesn't make it
so leave a [ __ ] dime she needs help
it's not like I don't have a heart okay
but your people started this whole
[ __ ] thing in the first place let's
not forget what you did it Prescott what
you did to our home pres God right that
whole situation was a damn mess it
happens it's over nothing I can do about
it now my niece is dead
you know you owe us this
now all of you lower your weapons might
be a good idea to play along here at
least for now you put him down I'll see
that as an expression of good faith nice
and easy
everybody put him down trip please play
the toss
please don't shoot us yeah it's not [ __ ]
okay hands behind your heads
oli we let him do this it's over we
can't give him another inch
no yes we're doing this the hard way
knock
what the hell's going on out here they
said they weren't here to hurt anybody
so I was trying to see if they oh my god
oh oh whoa what the [ __ ] what
[Music]
well that was unexpected
very unexpected cool oh sorry I forgot
now we got 62% of players told David
that Kate wanted to leave him
well that was 62 percent of players that
was tricked into another option I hated
that option that didn't make any sense
how did you handle the frontier 61%
opened fire so it was kind of a close
call what would you have done huh what
would you have done
did you trust Jesus haha 87% would have
trust in Jesus very good
how did you deal with Conrad's threat to
Clementine Oh a lot of people kill
Conrad I thought that was a really tough
decision to make
I suppose it makes sense that it's the
right decision but that doesn't make it
a tough decision
finally how far did you get into
Richmond uh-huh
I would say okay excellent
well that concludes another episode of
season three The Walking Dead I loved
playing this game and I'm so thrilled
that I can share it with you guys
through the power of the Internet we
have three more episodes to go let's
have a quick look here so coming soon
okay Jesus isn't that one that's cool
Clementine looking all badass in Episode
four and then all right it should be a
good one I'm really enjoying this one so
far I hope you are as well and hopefully
we can see some more familiar faces in
the next ones anyway thank you guys so
much for watching it's it's such an
amazing thing I really appreciate it and
as always stay